ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Hello, everybody, and welcome
back to "Android Design in
Action." My name
is Roman Nurik.
And with me here today
is Adam Koch--
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
ROMAN NURIK: --and
Nick Butcher.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello.
ROMAN NURIK: So today, we're
going to be talking about
shopping list apps and the
contextual action bar.
And before we jump in, I just
want to remind everybody what
this show is all about.
So on "Android Design in
Action," we take a look at
apps that have been previously
reviewed on "The App Clinic,"
which is on Fridays.
And we take a look at how we
can improve some of the
screens, some of the visual
designs in the screens of
those apps.
And then, more recently,
we've been diving
into specific topics.
For example, a few weeks ago,
we did responsive design,
meaning designing for tablets
and phones and basically any
screen size on a spectrum
of devices.
And today, like I said, we're
going to be talking about the
contextual action bar.
So let's jump in with the very
first app that we'll look at
which was reviewed last week on
"The App Clinic." And that
app is Grocery IQ.
So before we jump into the
redesign, let's talk about
what this app does.
And so this app basically lets
you manage a number of
different lists, or
shopping lists.
So let's say you have a favorite
bakery nearby or a
favorite supermarket nearby.
And you know that they sell
certain products.
So what you can do is you can
actually create a shopping
list and create or add items to
your list that are broken
up by the different stores in
which you would buy them.
So the bakery may have
breads and cereals
and things like that.
And the grocery store
or supermarket
may have other things.
So one of the key differences
between this app and other
shopping list apps is the
ability to kind of break
things up in that way.
Also, it lets you-- let's just
zoom into the screens here.
It lets you look at some
coupons for, I guess,
different products that you
may want to buy, maybe
contextually relevant or not.
It lets you store favorites.
It lets you do a lot of
different types of things.
So it's basically a shopping
list that lets you neatly
categorize your different items
and lets you also look
at coupons as well.
Before we jump in, have you
guys used this app at all?
Or do you have any other
thoughts on the initial
background on this app?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
ADAM KOCH: Not really.
Actually, I did try it
a little while back.
And unfortunately for me, when
I see the design looked kind
of dated like this, I usually go
and just sort of uninstall
it immediately.
So I didn't get to try it out
too much, unfortunately.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And this app, to be fair, is
using some of the older
patterns, some of the
Gingerbread styling with the
tabs, actually.
About a year or so ago,
they'd probably-- or
maybe two years ago--
those would be perfectly
normal tabs.
They're actually using the
correct guidelines for the
icons and so on and
so forth for tabs.
But it's really just
kind of dated.
That's exactly how I'd put it.
ADAM KOCH: And then, of course,
the Menu button, the
button of shame down the bottom
that the guys from "The
App Clinic" mentioned as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, the legacy
Menu button is something that
should really just go away.
And we have a solution
for that, anyway.
And the other issue here is that
it's using some of the
gradients that you'd find on
other platforms, kind of those
stark gradients, and
also these kind of
one-pixel text shadows.
This is something we haven't
talked about
before in this show.
But another thing that
developers do a lot aside from
gradients and things like that
is adding these tiny little
shadows to kind of give a sense
of depth to your text.
And in Android, that's
perfectly fine to do.
You can do it in a lot of cases,
but oftentimes it's
done without real thought
as to why.
Is there a reason
for doing this?
And I think, in this case, it
works fairly well because it's
very subtle.
But if you were to move over
to the Holo visual styling,
the new modern Android UI look
and feel, you should try to
avoid things like that, those
things that add a
subtle sense of depth.
It's almost unnecessary.
But again, it's totally fine
if the rest of your visual
design matches with that.
And the other thing that
we like to point out is
right-facing carets.
Actually, on the screen,
touching the list items here
doesn't really do anything.
It actually does nothing.
But to get into the details,
you actually have to touch
this secondary action or
the secondary touch
area on the list item.
And then to check the item, you
just touch this check box.
So some of these things
make sense, some
of them not so much.
So we wanted to kind of rethink
how you could approach
this screen and this
app in general.
So let's jump into the
redesign screen.
Hopefully, let's get to 100%.
OK.
So let's jump into the
redesign screen.
So as we always do, we've added
a proper action bar.
We've added some iconography,
some branding on the top left.
We added a single checkout
action button.
And if you'll notice back here,
checkout is something
that after you check the items
that you've purchased, you can
press Checkout.
And it moves those items into
your history, so that then
next time you're shopping or
such, you can just bring
things into your list directly
from your history.
So it's kind of a neat
little feature.
And we decided to move that
as a primary action
in the action bar.
We also added spinner navigation
at the top.
And we'll show details
on that in a second.
But basically, it lets
you switch between
the different stores.
And you'll see later, it lets
you manage stores and things
like that, as well.
And then, for the actual list
itself, we've presented the
same old list.
But to actually jump into the
details, you just touch once
on the text here.
And just as before, you can
check the box to the left to
mark it as complete.
But it doesn't actually move it
into a completely separate
area once it's checked.
It stays put, which is probably
a safer interaction,
a more consistent interaction.
The other thing I should mention
is that we've also
brought up coupons.
This is one thing I wanted
to talk about.
And it seems like coupons in
this app-- and I think the
developer is coupons.com--
seems like coupons are a fairly
important part of
either the business model, or
maybe it's revenue driving.
I don't really know.
But coupons seemed fairly
important, but they weren't
immediately visible.
So one way in which we tried to
bring that out more is to
make it more contextually
relevant.
So if there's a coupon for one
of the items in your list--
let's say at a store nearby
there's a coupon for it--
it'll show up as a secondary
action here with the number of
coupons found.
And then touching that
takes you to the
coupon detail screen.
And we also decided, why not
make coupons a secondary
section at the bottom?
Let's say I have
no list items.
I have nothing on my
shopping list.
Why not just show coupons?
Hey, I forgot to get soup
the other week.
And there's a coupon for soup.
So let me just pop that
into my shopping list.
But also, if you do have lots
of shopping list items, then
you're probably not so much
worried about other products.
You probably want to just get
rid of those products and buy
those, and not worry about
anything else.
And so coupons moves all the
way to the bottom of that.
And then we used a different
visual indicator, this kind of
almost faux torn edge.
And this is borderline
skeuomorphic, but it doesn't
really matter.
It's this secondary part of the
screen that shows you that
this is clearly a different
part of the app and a
different set of items.
So it's a clear visual
delineation.
And then we've also used this
blue accent color throughout
to indicate that this
is a coupon.
Kind of like on google.com, you
see the text ads in search
results on a yellow
background.
This would be kind of similar.
So you present a visual theme
throughout that says, hey,
blue is advertising,
or blue is coupons.
And green is your stuff.
So it's kind of one of the
ways to think about that.
And the last thing I want to
point out on this screen
before-- if you guys
want to chime in--
is this bar at the top.
And this is something that
Adam and I talked about
beforehand, and Nick
as well, I believe.
Is really how do you present
adding items or
searching for stuff?
And in this case, searching and
adding is really part of
the same flow.
And we decided to make it kind
of a first-class citizen
rather than an action button.
We've put it in line at the
very top of the list.
So that's all I want
to mention.
Adam, I remember you had
thoughts on search and add.
You want to talk about
some alternatives?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
I guess one thing I wanted to
talk about was you can always
have an action item.
But if the action is really
important, you can put it in
line like Roman has
shown here.
But I guess if you did want to,
you could move that Add or
Search box back into the action
bar as an action item,
and maybe trigger the sort of
contextual search that shows
directly in the action
bar itself.
So that's just an alternative,
totally up to the designer of
the app as to how they
actually want
to implement this.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, almost an
expanding search view.
But maybe it's an expanding
add view.
ADAM KOCH: An interesting
approach.
ROMAN NURIK: In one of the later
apps, Nick will talk
about some similar ways in which
he approached this in
Out of Milk.
But anyway, let's move on to
the next screen, in the
interest of time.
So the next screen-- again,
since this is about the
contextual action bar, this is
just briefly showing that--
let's say I wanted to
immediately take action on
three or four of those items.
I can just long press
to start selection.
And that pops up the contextual
action bar at the top.
And then keep single touching
different items in my list to
add or remove from
the selection.
And then take action on
that entire selection.
So in this case, I've selected
Hoegaarden and Macallan.
Hopefully I've spelled
Macallan right--
Hoegaarden and Macallan.
And then let's say I've gone
ahead and bought those items
at the store.
I could just select both and
press Mark Purchased.
to take action immediately
on those two items.
In the next screen, this is an
example of that dropdown.
And this is kind
of interesting.
This is something that we took
a few liberties with.
Dropdown/Spinner navigation--
usually, you just see the items
which you're switching
between, right?
So in a normal case, you'd see
Grocery Store, Bakery, or Any
Store, meaning all
of the above.
But in this case, since this
is the single place where
users see their list
of stores--
this is the most visible place
in the app where they see
their list of stores.
Let's make it easy to also then
take action on that list,
to then maybe add a store to
that list right from here.
This is something that Ian
mentioned last week on "The
App Clinic." It's a missed
opportunity if you see a list
of things, and you know want to
add one, but you then can't
figure out how to do it.
So this way, it makes
it very obvious.
It's a slight deviation from
the standard pattern, but I
personally feel that it's a
fairly reasonable deviation.
And then the other thing is that
there's also Favorites
and History.
And to navigate to those items--
and again, they're
still lists of tasks, really,
at the end of the day--
you can jump into Favorites and
History right from here
with this separate section.
So any criticisms or thoughts
or alternatives?
ADAM KOCH: Well, why don't we
throw it over to Nick quickly?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
For me, looking at the original
design, it just
screamed Gingerbread to me.
I think the refresh that you've
given it makes it look
much more modern, much more at
home on my device running
Jelly Bean or whatever the
latest OS everyone is running.
And also, it feels
easier to use.
Because the standard iconography
and the standard
controls from the modern
palette just are
very familiar to me.
So I think this is a really
lovely redesign.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, thank you.
And one other thing that we
should probably talk about at
the end is the difference
between
selection and check boxes.
And there's lots of different
ways you can go about this.
And I think, Nick, you tried an
alternative in Out of Milk.
But we should definitely talk
about at the very end if we
have some time.
Since that's something that
specifically with task list
apps, or list apps, that can
be confusing in some cases.
So the last screen that
we have here is
with editing a store.
And then we'll jump over
to Out of Milk.
So when editing a store, you
have the option to edit the
store name.
And then if you'll notice here,
you can add or reorder
aisles, as well as
hide aisles.
But it seems like in this
case, this is really a
sub-dashboard pattern.
Rather than giving you the
content immediately--
the list of aisles--
it just gives you the options
in which you can
take on that list.
So rather than doing that, we
felt that it would be just a
better user experience to
show everything at once.
So you can immediately edit the
name, as well as reorder
and hide aisles.
And we're also using
the Done, Discard
pattern at the very top.
So rather than seeing a Save
button or anything like that,
we see very clear options to
either cancel what we just did
or save by pressing
the Done button.
And then here, you'll notice
that we used these subtle drag
handles to allow you
to reorder items.
And then the entire rest of that
touch area is a single
touch target to show or hide.
So touching it basically
toggles its visibility.
And you'll notice that there
isn't a separator between this
visibility marker and the
rest of the list item.
And that's to indicate that it's
a single touch target,
not two separate targets.
And then obviously, you can add
an aisle by pressing the
Plus button there.
And of course, if you long
touch, maybe there should be a
contextual action bar
there as well.
Haven't really mocked
it up, but yeah.
So anyway-- parting thoughts
for Grocery IQ, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: I think the direct
manipulation is much
better than having to go
through each level.
I think the same way you set
these coupons up to a high
level, it makes it easier to use
if you don't have to pogo
stick, as they say, in and
out of different screens.
ADAM KOCH: I also like that
coupons tear-off that you have
at the bottom there.
Just because as you say, it's
probably important to their
business, as the company itself
is called Coupons.
But also, it sort of dynamically
grows and shrinks
based on what the real content
is on that particular screen.
So I think it's a nice
way of showing
everything on one screen.
ROMAN NURIK: The other thing is
that if you have an empty
list, if you have no items in
that list, then naturally, you
think, oh, let's just show no
items in this list text.
And that's it, right?
So the user opens up the app.
And they immediately
see an empty list.
And so showing coupons is
another way of presenting more
useful information without
having to fill the space with
useless stuff.
ADAM KOCH: Likewise, if the list
is really, really long,
those coupons aren't going to
get directly in your way.
They're going to get pushed
down off the screen.
And the content is still going
to be seen there at the front.
ROMAN NURIK: And worst case, if
you find that users don't
interact with coupons as much
because of that, then you can
always have an overflow item
or something else in the
action bar or something that
leads you to that screen.
So let's jump into
Out of Milk.
How much time do we have?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, we're good.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so let's
jump into Out of Milk.
Nick, do you want to talk
about Out of Milk?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So Out of Milk is a to-do list
type application, but very
focused on shopping lists.
So when you come in, it gives
you free ready-made list
selections like a shopping
list, a to-do list, and
something else I forget.
So it's quite focused on that.
There's a slight twist on
the regular to-do list.
It's got some extra
functionality in there.
So you can see here in the
action bar, you have the
ability to use a barcode
scanner,
which is kind of cool.
So you can add items to it.
And you also have the option
to add some metadata around
each of the items
in your list.
So for example, you
can see milk here.
You can give it a price.
And then you can get a summary
of the total price remaining
in your basket of goods to
pick up at the bottom.
You come in a dashboard path.
And I've dived into one of the
main screens, managing, like
viewing a list.
And you have this kind of
spinner navigation for
flitting between the two.
I think when I look at this
screen, the first thing that
stands out to me is that despite
the fact they're using
an action bar and have an
overflow button there.
They also have the button of
shame, as we're calling it,
the emulated menu button
down at the bottom.
And so this is kind of
perplexing to me that they
have both, especially because
the emulated button doesn't
really do anything down
at the bottom.
They're just setting a target
SDK of 10, I believe, even
though they're providing
styles and using
ActionBarSherlock, I believe,
to have an action bar on the
platforms that support it.
There's a few issues as well.
If you take a look at
their action bar--
I think, to speak to some of the
points that Roman's made
in the past, about if you're
going to use an action bar,
kind of really try and follow
the standard patterns to it
and don't deviate
away from it.
So first up with the action
bar-- say the overflow button
is too heavy styled,
if you look at the
normal action bars.
The overflow is slightly
less prominent.
It's got a 50% opacity in order
to de-emphasize the
secondary tasks compared
to the primary actions.
And also some of the
icons don't already
have the hollow styling.
And if you look at the spinner,
the spinner isn't
really attached to the
shopping list.
It's off and over, across
to the side.
which is especially
bad in tablets.
When if you're in landscape in
a tablet, it's kind of 3/4 of
the screen away from the thing
it's supposed to be marking up
as being clickable.
There's some delimiters
between the icons.
And on top of that, there's
also a fair amount of
skeuomorphic style and really
non-Holo, non-native platform
styling in the application.
Any other thoughts on the apps
from you guys before we dive
into what we've done with it?
ADAM KOCH: It's like they've
gone halfway with the
skeuomorphic thing, but not all
the way, which is almost
worse than just going all
the m if you ask me.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's
kind of tough.
I think you guys are right
that it's a bit too
skeuomorphic.
But at the same time, I feel
like following the
interactions--
to me personally--
is first and foremost.
And to me, the greater
issue here is with
the legacy Menu button.
Things like that just
fundamentally break some of
the expectations that
users have.
But yeah, I do agree that
the skeuomorphism--
there's a spectrum, right?
There's pure minimalism, and
then pure skeuomorphism or
realism, whatever.
And I feel like they chose a
place on that spectrum that's
a little further to the right.
NICK BUTCHER: Now, before we go
into the redesign, just a
few words on the interaction
design here.
So the way the app currently
works, if you single tap on an
item in the list, it then pops
up an old-style quick action
bar, which lets you do things
like edit it or mark it as
done, for example.
And if you long press on an
item, it then puts a score
through it and moves
it to the bottom,
denoting that it's done.
So you kind of have
these two levels.
So if it's an item on the list,
then you can have it
scored through.
Or then you can actually
delete it to
totally remove it.
There's many permutations of
state which an item can be in.
And because of this-- if you
just close the Overflow menu.
I don't think we've got a
screenshot of it here.
But if you do, there is a
plethora of options there.
You actually have to scroll
it on a Galaxy Nexus.
There's that many overflow
options, which I found to be a
bit-- kind of overloaded me.
ROMAN NURIK: This is kind of
against the concept of direct
manipulation, which is one of
the design principles in a
design guide.
Items should be manipulable.
You should be able to touch
them, to interact with them.
Rather than choosing actions
somewhere else to do things
like trigger selection, or
Select All, Deselect All.
Anything like that should really
be more contextual.
And in general, if you look at
just for long press, I think
that's particularly egregious
in this case, where we've
tried to standardize on
what long press means.
And really, it means
selection.
It triggers selection and then
potentially showing actions on
your selection.
So using it for anything else
like marking an item as
complete, it's kind of beyond
what the standards are.
And it's just another thing
that users have to learn.
One other thing that we use
for long press is when you
long press on an action button,
on an icon-only
button, it shows you
a little tool tip.
But that's a secondary
use for it.
It's not as important
a use as selection.
Nick, I just wanted to mention
that I've been showing your
redesign already by accident.
So unfortunately, we don't
have a big reveal.
But go ahead and jump in.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, so if we do
take a look at the redesign
that you've been looking at for
all this time, then we can
see we've applied some
Holo styling to it.
So we've used some familiar
language--
visual language-- in the
application to make it a bit
easier to see.
It's actually quite interesting
that Roman and I
did our redesigns in isolation
and have used some quite
similar metaphors, like the
drag handles, and so on,
throughout.
But I guess that's why they're
standard, right?
But the other thing I didn't
really mention there's some
really cool information and cool
actions you can do buried
in the overflow menu
on the original.
Such as to share this
list with someone
else, or send it to--
using the Android Sharing with
intents, which is kind of lost
in all the noise in the Overflow
menu, I thought.
So one of the main things--
apart from applying Holo styling
to the look and feel--
is I've promoted Add to being
this permanent in-line action,
similar to--
and Roman did with the
Search and Add.
So you have this bar there,
which breaks out of the
standard [? ribbon ?] of the
rest of the page in order to
make it more prominent.
And I've also broken down--
using the microphone or
the barcode as kind of
sub-actions of adding.
They're different kind
of ways of adding an
item to your list.
So they belong together
rather than having
separate action items.
So by bringing Add into the
page itself, it's given me
some room in the action bar to
promote some of the unique and
very, very cool functionality
that this application offers.
And then tuck the less used
and much smaller set of
alternative actions under
the Overflow.
So we've also changed up the
interaction a little
bit here, as well.
You can see I've placed some
check boxes next to the items,
which allow you to go into
a selection mode.
So I've actually kind of flipped
the concept or changed
the concept a little bit and
got rid of the idea of a
semi-struck-through done state,
and just gone straight
to a dismissed state.
So I decided to use the Swipe
to Dismiss pattern that's
we're seeing gaining traction
these days as the way
to mark items off.
So this is speaking to Roman's
point about direct
manipulation of your data being
much more satisfying.
So what you can actually do--
yeah, here we go-- is
you can swipe--
ROMAN NURIK: This is like Swipe
to Complete, rather than
Swipe to Delete.
I wrote Swipe to Delete here,
but it's like Swipe to mark as
completed, basically, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So this is a bit of a change
to the pattern.
Because I guess in the old way,
you would long press it.
It'd be struck through, so it'd
still be able to get it
back quickly.
So it's a way to give you that
safety net, that way to easily
recover any data that you've
marked as complete.
We've also used a
new pattern--
an emerging pattern--
of the Undo.
So when you swipe away an item
to say it's done, we actually
temporarily showed this Undo
option in line where it was.
The idea here being that until
you interact with the screen
again, this will stay there.
So it gives you this chance to
say, oh, actually I checked
the wrong item, whatever.
But the minute you start
scrolling or touching another
item, the idea is that
this would close up.
ROMAN NURIK: The next one-- the
quick return-- you want to
talk about that?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So this is to go with the idea
that we've made Add this
really prominent item.
But we wanted to cope with the
case that you might be having
too many layers of
items at the top.
You have an action bar.
Sometimes you might have
tabs, if you had an
in-line program action.
You end up running out of room,
especially if you're in,
say, landscape view, where you
have less vertical space.
So I'm using here a pattern
which we've been dubbing Quick
Return, which I think is a
really, really cool way too
handle that problem.
So the idea here is if you
had a lot of items--
so here I'm making lasagna.
And I've got a lot of
items in my list.
As they scroll away, the Add
button, the horizontal bar,
will scroll out of view.
But the minute they start
dragging back down, it'll jump
right back in and be
this floating item.
So what this really does, it
lets you maximize the amount
of space you have to play with
in the screen and show the
items on the list.
So if you're searching through
the list, looking for a
particular item to check off,
then it gives you the maximum
space to present that.
But it makes adding a new item
super simple and always very
convenient to do.
ROMAN NURIK: This is similar to
like you mentioned, Google
Now and also Google+
has this, right?
So Google+, if you're in the
stream and if you scroll down,
the buttons that let you post
to the stream scroll off.
But then as soon as you start
slowly inching up again, it
pops those back in.
So should we move on to
contextual actions?
NICK BUTCHER: So the next thing
I wanted to cover here--
so in the old application, if
you touch an item, you get
this quick bar which lets you
perform a number of actions
upon a single item.
So the new way of doing this
really is using the contextual
action bar.
So here, if you long press or
tap on the check mark, you go
into this contextual
selection mode.
So here, we selected one item.
And using the contextual action
bar, you can edit.
Or the second icon on the action
bar there is you can
move it to another list
or delete the item
straight from there.
The power of using the
contextual action bar, I
believe, is not only this very
consistent with the platform
way of handling selection.
But it's also great for dealing
with multi-select.
So here you can see the
[INAUDIBLE] which says one
item selected is actually
a dropdown.
So right here, I could
just close that.
And you might get options
to Select All.
Or in this example
here, I've tapped
another item on the list.
And it's letting me do
contextual actions.
So here you can see because
I'm dealing with two
selections rather than one,
we've actually refined the
selections.
So we said that Edit
might not be
applicable to multiple items.
And it's refined it down to
using two actions here.
So it's a very neat way of
performing quite powerful
selection actions.
ROMAN NURIK: So unless you
have a batch edit mode or
something where you batch apply
a tag or something, then
removing that Edit
icon makes sense.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
And just for fun to stick with
the metaphor we've been using,
of using the swipe to mark
something that's completed.
We thought we'd keep if
[? where if you ?] are
selecting multiple items at
once, you could then still
swipe across on one
of these items.
And it would mark each
of them as completed.
ROMAN NURIK: That's cool.
I've never seen that done
before, but that looks like it
might work really,
really well.
It's very cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Just a fun idea.
ADAM KOCH: It'd be kind of cool
to hint that you can do
that by when the user selects
the actual contextual action
item, you could have the
animation play, and have the
Undo in place still.
And that way they know next
time, they could probably just
go and swipe themselves.
I like that.
That's cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this might
be one of those cases we
talked about in the showcase
view last week where if there
isn't something completely
apparent by what's on screen
like a gesture you
have to perform.
I think it's OK to hint that the
first time the user sees
it that you could show some
kind of animation saying--
because it's [INAUDIBLE]
to do this, to mark
something as done.
I think it wouldn't be too
egregious to show it on the
first run and teach the
user something.
ROMAN NURIK: I also just
wanted to point out--
that's a great thing that you've
pointed out-- is that
showing an animation
hints at a gesture.
So for example, when you have
a tab, or tabs with a
ViewPager, when you switch tabs,
you call page or that
set current item.
But calling that actually
slides the contents.
So it's a subtle hint that you
can actually then throw your
finger on the glass and
start swiping across
the different tabs.
So that's definitely a good way
to hint at a gesture, is
to show an animation that
replays the gesture basically
without the user interacting.
All right.
So let's jump into a few other
examples of the contextual
action bar, since we wanted
to talk about it.
Before we jump into
all the details--
oh wow, we're super
low on time.
So we're going to have
to fly through this.
Contextual action bar basically
lets you show
multiple actions
on a selection.
Or it enters a mode, basically,
where you can take
action on selections.
Anybody else have anything to
add on contextual action bars?
ADAM KOCH: And we're done.
ROMAN NURIK: Because we're
running super low on time.
OK, you know what?
Rather than do that,
let's just fly
through some of these.
These are just some examples
of apps that use it.
So the gallery lets you take
actions on multiple photos.
Gmail lets you take action
on multiple items.
And then this is an open source
example, a Google I/O
app, which basically
lets you--
it shows a contextual action
bar for this master detail
flow on a tablet.
So if you select multiple
items-- even if you're looking
at one, or a different one,
you can take action items
without even looking at them.
And this is another example of
an app called Tasks, by Team
Tasks, that lets you take
actions like Indent or
Unindent, I guess, different
items within a
task list all at once.
NICK BUTCHER: On the contextual
action bar, I'd say
you might've guessed that
we're huge fans
of the action bar.
Because it's familiar and very
powerful and very flexible.
So using contextual action bar
lets you have the same power
of the action bar but to do
these contextual actions.
So you can still do things
like have the
split action bar.
So Gmail on phones, for example,
has a plethora of
options which [INAUDIBLE]
you can do on an email.
So you could still use that
split action bar to offer up
all those different things,
so I'm a big fan of it.
ROMAN NURIK: Definitely
use it if you can.
And I believe ActionBarSherlock
also
supports the contextual
action bar.
So you don't have to worry about
backwards compatibility
and things with that.
Anyway, let's fly through.
Next week--
that's it for the content for
the show today-- actually, I
guess we have design
news in a bit.
Next week, we're going to be
doing a Google+ Hangout.
And we'd like to invite
you all to join.
So if you're interested in
talking to us live on this
show at this same time, and if
you want to ask us questions.
Or if you want to show some of
your work by screen sharing,
or if you just want to rant
about Android design, please
let us know if you can join.
If you can make it, let us
know in the comments--
pretty much anywhere--
and we'll invite you next week,
maybe about 10 or 15
minutes before the show airs.
And then we'll have a 30-minute
Hangout to discuss.
And we may be announcing
giveaways or
anything like that.
So you may want to tune in.
And definitely, like I said, let
us know if you can join.
But let's fly through
Android design news.
We don't have that much.
Nick, do you want to talk about
your live redesign?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think I
mentioned last week that I was
visiting Berlin for
a DevFest event.
And I'd gone onstage to do
a live app redesign.
So I was looking at a pretty
cool app, actually, to control
the lights in the building we
were in, which had an API.
But it was a kind of
thrown-together demo where it
didn't really have the best,
most modern Android UI.
So I was live talking through
some things we could change.
Well, a very talented
designer, Marie--
pretty regularly I've mentioned
on this show--
was using her awesome
Illustrator skills to throw
together these designs.
So this-- as you can see, where
I've just zoomed in on--
25 minutes' work, we managed
to throw together a pretty
cool-looking redesign.
So yeah, you can follow the QR
code to see a recording of
that talk if you're
interested.
ROMAN NURIK: Very well done.
It was super fast.
She works super fast
in Illustrator.
It's crazy.
NICK BUTCHER: Actually, while
we're talking about Marie--
one more plug for her.
She's just opened up an Etsy
shop, so she has these amazing
paintings of Androids.
So if you're a fan of fan art
for Android, then look her up
on Google+.
And find her Etsy shop and
buy a Droid [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: And I think the
last news item is there's a
blog post recently that talks
about the different units used
in Android.
So DIPs, Density Independent
Pixels.
Also SP units, Scale
Independent Pixels.
If you're still confused about
the difference between pixels
and DIPs and SPs and all those
different things, and density,
read this blog post.
It's a fairly good primer.
We also have good documentation
on it, but this
may be a simpler way of
looking at things.
And that was by Edwin
Evans, who I've
never heard of before.
But thanks, Edwin, for the
awesome blog post.
All right, so that's it for this
week on "Android Design
and Action." Thanks for tuning
in, and sorry we ran
a little bit late.
Unfortunately, we had
too much content.
That's always a good problem
to have, too much content.
NICK BUTCHER: We just
talk too much.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, well.
Anyway, thanks again
for joining.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Nick Butcher.
ADAM KOCH: See you
guys next week.
ROMAN NURIK: See you guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]